now the Biden Administration knows it's
getting squeezed by its base over the
issue of support for Israel and the
progressive base knows who they might be
able to mold kamla Harris children
continue to die at the wall because of
this country's inhumane policies much
like the policies against those in
Palestine first of all a terrorist
organization Hamas struck Israel in the
way that it did I think it is important
to recognize also the distinction
between a terrorist organization Hamas
and the Palestinian people and
civilians and they should not be
conflated she's very smart is kamla
seeing an opportunity here maybe the
base turning against Biden but she can
kind of split the baby here I'm on your
side don't worry wink wink but even her
former AIDS know she's kind of can be
influenced political reporting that a
letter is being circulated among them
urging her to seek an immediate
ceasefire between Israel and Hamas and
calling Israel's Gaza campaign a
genocide joining me now is tulsy gabt
former Hawaii congresswoman lieutenant
colonel in the Army Reserve as well in
Fox News contributor telsey um they
obviously know they have a problem here
with significant percentage of their own
base what's kamla up to there I I don't
know if kamla knows what she's up to uh
but the reality here is when you look at
things like uh what representative Corey
bush is saying what the squad is saying
what so many of these other people are
saying who are accusing Israel of
committing a genocide it it is the
height of hypocrisy because they're
apologists and supporters of these
islamist Hamas terrorists who are
calling for a genocide the extermination
of all Jews not just in Israel but
around the world and we're seeing this
being carried out by these violent mobs
and threats and other things that are
happening against Jewish people
literally uh around the world and the
worst part is they're doing this under
the guise of well we care about innocent
people and we don't want people to get
hurt when in fact um they are in in
essence supporting and apologizing for
the barbaric actions of Hamas against
innocent women children and civilians I
called it creating the monster like
they're Dr Frankenstein and now the
monster in their Progressive Wing is
turning against them and but they're
trying to pretend like they're oh this
is kind of a shocking development it's
not a shocking development this has
always been there but it's also deeply
anti-American is it not it it is and it
is against the very foundational
principles and values of who we are uh
as a country uh these Democrats they
have called people like me and
islamophobe for many years just just for
speaking the truth about radical Islam
about the threat that this islamism
poses to the freedom and peace and
security of the American people and
people around the world well do you uh
believe as to some of these Republicans
in the Senate that we should be bringing
in more Afghan refugees we brought in
what 80 90,000 we didn't fet any of them
I'm sure some of them are great people
and helped us in in Afghanistan but do
we do we have 80,000 interpreters and or
drivers I mean I don't think so there
are there are many unquestionably but
just like we're so concerned about
Biden's open borders and the fact that
we've got millions of people coming in
who are not vetted in any way shape or
form who have not been checked they
share our values to Nigel farage's Point
as to what you're seeing in England this
is a this is they say oh you can't call
it a class clash of civilizations why
not it is a clash of civilization no
women's rights no belief in plural
pluralism uh you know the Dignity of the
individual free expression none of that
no that's not on the table no and that
that is the hypocrisy of seeing these
you know the lgbtqia activists out there
holding and waving the trans flag
combined with the Palestinian Flags like
they don't they don't know and
understand what this islamist ideology
is this radical Islam ideology where
they actually want to kill people they
want to kill those people specific they
have to tie Ukraine to Israel because
they know Ukraine won't stand on its own
funding and again they're trying to
cheat the American people through their
representatives by saying okay you
support and you want to stand with
Israel well guess what we're going to
sneak in all of this other money that
we're going to take out of your pocket
and your bank account to go and support
something that increasingly Americans
are understanding not this proxy war
against Russia is pushing us closer to
nuclear war and it's not in our best
National Security interest to do that oh
telsey great to see you always hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else